It's 1984. Ronald Reagan is president. MTV is just three years old. And it's the era of the Death Wish movies. This is the story of a man who decided to clean up the most violent town in the world. If you've never seen the Death Wish movies, they follow the actor Charles Bronson as he goes on a shooting spree to, depending on the movie, avenge the murder of his wife. wife or the murders of other ordinary New Yorkers who fall prey to the city's wildest, most violent criminals. The plot sort of doesn't matter in a weird way. This is historian Heather Ann Thompson, author of the new book, Fear and Fury. What matters is that the audience is relating to this feeling of always unsettled when you leave
现在是1984年。罗纳德·里根担任总统。MTV问世仅仅三年。这也是《猛龙怪客》系列电影的时代。这是一个关于某个男人决定整顿世界上暴力色彩最浓厚的城市的故事。如果你从未看过《猛龙怪客》系列，它们讲述了演员查尔斯·布朗森（Charles Bronson）大开杀戒的故事，根据剧情的不同，是为了替他被谋杀的妻子报仇，或是为其他成为这座城市最疯狂、最暴力罪犯牺牲品的普通纽约客复仇。从某种奇怪的角度来看，剧情其实并不重要。这是历史学家希瑟·安·汤普森（Heather Ann Thompson），新书《恐惧与愤怒》（Fear and Fury）的作者。重要的是，观众能够产生共鸣，感受到那种一离开
your apartment or your home. and that at any given moment, some young black or brown thug will cause you harm. The 80s were full of movies like this, Death Wish, The Exterminator, the Dirty Harry movies. This is kind of a glorified, vigilante genre of media. Every man for himself, make sure you're armed. Take out any would-be assailant on your own. Make sure that you're protecting your family. And that every man for himself message resonated with people.
你的公寓或家时就总是坐立不安的情感。并且在任何特定时刻，某个年轻的黑人或棕色人种暴徒都会对你造成伤害。80年代充满了这样的电影，《猛龙怪客》、《除恶金刚》、《肮脏的哈里》电影。这是一种美化的、私刑正义流派的媒体。人人为己，确保自己全副武装。独自消灭任何潜在的袭击者。确保你在保护你的家人。而这种“人人为己”的信息引起了人们的共鸣。
All the movies came out in what was actually a very difficult moment in cities like New York. This is four years into the Reagan Revolution. Cities have been stripped of a lot of their social resources and trash is piling up on the city streets. Muggings are up. The drug trade is up. The city is feeling dangerous. There's mainly a sense that nobody is doing anything about any of this. There's a real lack of understanding of why are cities feeling so under siege.
所有这些电影上映时，纽约等城市的处境其实非常艰难。这是里根革命的第四年。城市的许多社会资源被剥削殆尽，城市街道上垃圾堆积如山。抢劫案增加。毒品交易增加。这座城市让人感到危险。人们普遍有一种感觉，那就是没有人对这一切采取任何行动。人们真正缺乏理解的是，为什么城市会感觉如此腹背受敌。
Then in 1984, something tragic happens in New York City. A white man named Bernie Getz, fed up with the crime and violence of the city, boards the subway, and shoots four black teenagers. None of them have weapons. But as the story spreads and becomes a headline in papers across the city, it starts transforming into a fantasy pulled right out of Death Wish, complete with dangerous armed criminals. You know, they're not always necessarily going to have the gun, right? But they're going to have something. They're going to slash you with jagged glass or they're going to whip out a tire iron. And in the Bernie Gett's case, there's sort of a new version of this, which is that young teenagers in the city are carrying screwdrivers.
然后在1984年，纽约市发生了一起悲剧。一个名叫伯尼·格茨（Bernie Getz）的白人男子，对城市的犯罪和暴力感到厌烦，他登上地铁，枪击了四名黑人青少年。他们都没有武器。但随着故事传播开来并成为全城各大报纸的头条，它开始演变成一出直接从《猛龙怪客》中搬出来的幻想，里面充满了危险的武装罪犯。你知道，他们不一定总是随身带着枪，对吧？但他们会带着别的东西。他们会用锯齿状的玻璃割伤你，或者他们会掏出轮胎撬棍。而在伯尼·格茨的案子里，出现了一种类似的新版本，那就是城里的年轻青少年带着螺丝刀。
Not just screwdrivers, sharpened screwdrivers, as in the normal tool transformed into a piercing deadly weapon. Only, it was completely made up. The teens were not carrying sharpened screwdrivers or any other kind of weapon. That was the invention of this one moment in 1984. A sneaky new weapon and a powerful symbol. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, how the mythical sharpened screwdriver at the heart of the Bernie Gets shooting
不仅仅是螺丝刀，而是削尖的螺丝刀，就像普通工具变成了致命的穿刺武器一样。只是，这完全是凭空捏造的。这些青少年并没有携带削尖的螺丝刀或任何其他类型的武器。那是1984年这一特定时刻的发明。一种隐秘的新武器和一个强有力的象征。从《无形百分之一》（99% Invisible）和BBC工作室（BBC Studios），这里是100件物品中的美国历史。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。今天，探讨伯尼·格茨枪击案核心中那把神话般的削尖螺丝刀是如何
surfaced a new era of misinformation and why it's still invoked as a justification for white vigilante violence today. Before the four teenagers in the Gets case became known as sharpened screwdriver wielding criminals, they were just four kids in the South Bronx. If New York was in bad shape, the South Bronx was in catastrophic shape. This is Elliot Williams, legal analysts and author of a book on Gets called Five Bullets. The mid-19 days were a quite a significant period of transition. Certainly, just about everything withdrew as the city tightened.
引发了新一轮的错误信息时代，以及为什么它至今仍被援引为白人私刑暴力的正义借口。在格茨案中的四名青少年被称为挥舞削尖螺丝刀的罪犯之前，他们只是南布朗克斯的四个孩子。如果说纽约的状况很糟糕，那南布朗克斯的状况简直就是灾难性的。这是埃利奥特·威廉姆斯（Elliot Williams），法律分析师兼一本关于格茨的书《五颗子弹》（Five Bullets）的作者。80年代中期是一个相当重要的转型时期。当然，随着城市勒紧裤腰带，几乎所有东西都在撤出。
its belt. Firemen, police, sanitation workers, gone. Public schools were decimated and stuck in the middle of that were four young men, Barry Allen, Darrell Kaby, Troy Candy, and James Ramsour. They were all between 18 and 19 years old and lived in a subsidized housing project called Claremont Village in the Bronx. Like Bernie, the four teenagers were soon to become famous, but we still actually don't know much about their lives. I tried to speak to all. I tried to speak to All of the surviving young men, two of the four are surviving. I tried very hard to speak to them. I got as close as speaking to two of Daryl K.B.'s sisters for the book, but they did not want to be on the record or quoted in the book, and I respected that.
消防员、警察、环卫工人，全都消失了。公立学校遭到毁灭性打击，而处于漩涡中心的是四名年轻人：巴里·艾伦（Barry Allen）、达雷尔·卡比（Darrell Cabey）、特洛伊·坎蒂（Troy Canty）和詹姆斯·拉姆索尔（James Ramseur）。他们当时都在18到19岁之间，住在布朗克斯一个名为克莱蒙特村（Claremont Village）的补贴住房项目中。就像伯尼一样，这四名青少年很快就会出名，但实际上我们对他们的生活仍然知之甚少。我试着和所有人交谈。我试着和所有幸存的年轻人交谈，四人中有两人幸存。我非常努力地想和他们交流。为了这本书，我曾差一点就能和达雷尔·卡比的两个姐姐交谈，但她们不想公开露面，也不想在书中被引用，我尊重这一点。
Still, there are some small details. We do know. We know they had siblings. We know James Rameshaw was a talented break dancer. We know that Barry Allen was a young father. We know Darryl Kaby ultimately is raised for most of his childhood by only his mother. because his father, who had been working as a taxi driver, had been crushed by his own cab in a carjacking. And his mother very much wanted more for him, wanted him to get away from all of the pressures and troubles of the South Bronx to sort of find a better life.
不过，确实有一些细节是我们知道的。我们知道他们有兄弟姐妹。我们知道詹姆斯·拉姆索尔是一个很有天赋的霹雳舞者。我们知道巴里·艾伦是一个年轻的父亲。我们知道达雷尔·卡比的童年大部分时间主要由他的母亲抚养长大。因为他的父亲曾是一名出租车司机，在一次劫车事件中被自己的出租车压死。他的母亲非常希望他能有更好的前途，希望他能远离南布朗克斯的所有压力和麻烦，从而找到更好的生活。
But at this point in 1984, none of them had been able to get away. So these are four kids who are hanging around essentially day. after day and have no money, no jobs, no prospects, but who still, of course, want to go on a date, want to play a video game, want to be a teenager. And so they decide on December 22, 1984, that they're going to go into the city and they're going to go to a video arcade because video arcades had machines that you could take a screwdriver, jimmy open, the receptacle, and you could get some quarters out of it. And in 1984, if you got a bunch of quarters, that was the difference between you being able to get something to eat, between you being able to imagine maybe
但在1984年的这个时刻，他们谁也没能离开。所以这四个孩子基本上是日复一日地在街头闲荡，没有钱，没有工作，没有前途，但他们当然还是想去约会，想玩电子游戏，想当个青少年。于是他们在1984年12月22日决定，他们要进城去一家游戏机厅，因为游戏机厅里有机器，你可以用螺丝刀撬开投币口，然后就能弄到一些25美分硬币。在1984年，如果你弄到了一堆硬币，那就决定了你能不能吃上饭，决定了你能不能想象也许
taking your girlfriend to the movies. That was the difference between having a life and not having a life. But I will note, it was not that they were the sort of street gang who were out marauding or wilding or whatever else. This was a common act that teenagers did. I mean, this was the golden age of arcade games. Pac-Man, Donkey Kong. These games were everywhere. You're talking liquor stores, bodegas, bowling alleys. It was painfully easy for someone with a long screwdriver and a little ingenuity to just pop it open.
带女朋友去看电影。那是有生活和没有生活的区别。但我要指出的是，他们并不是那种四处掠夺、胡闹或其他什么的街头帮派。这是青少年常做的一件事。我的意思是，那是街机游戏的黄金时代。吃豆人（Pac-Man）、大金刚（Donkey Kong）。这些游戏无处不在。你说的是酒类专卖店、小卖部、保龄球馆。对于一个拿着长螺丝刀又有点小聪明的人来说，轻而易举就能把它撬开，
and run away with all of that money in it. And in many respects was cleaner or safer than mugging or robbing someone. It wasn't that police were likely to move heaven and earth to try to track down a kid with $80 of quarters in his pocket. And even if you got caught, you wouldn't go to jail for a long time. So three days before Christmas, 1984, when the city is bustling and people are scrambling to get last-minute gifts, the four teenagers get on a train to go to an arcade downtown. They got on, they jumped the turnstile in the South Bronx. We're goofing off.
然后带着里面所有的钱逃跑。在很多方面，这比抢劫或打劫某人更干净或更安全。警察也不太可能会翻山越岭去追踪一个口袋里装着80美元硬币的孩子。而且就算被抓了，也不会坐很久的牢。所以在1984年圣诞节前三天，当城市一片繁华、人们正争先恐后地购买压轴礼物时，这四名青少年坐上了去市中心游戏机厅的火车。他们上了车，在南布朗克斯跳过旋转闸门。我们在胡闹。
They were certainly doing pull-ups on the bars, walking around, asking people for cigarettes or for matches or whatever else. Meanwhile, Bertie Gets in Manhattan, about 30 minutes south of the Bronx on the train, is about to leave his apartment. He's had a frustrating morning, and he decides that he's going to get on a train. And he's going to go down and potentially see some friends, maybe have. have a drink or two, but whatever, get out of the apartment. And so he leaves mid-afternoon to walk very nearby to the 14th Street Station. He gets on the two train going downtown and onto this one car, there are these four teenagers. They were having a really good time.
他们当然在单杠上做引体向上，四处走动，向人们讨烟或火柴或其他东西。与此同时，在曼哈顿的伯尼·格茨，距离布朗克斯向南约30分钟火车车程的地方，正准备离开他的公寓。他度过了一个令人沮丧的早晨，他决定去坐火车。他要下去可能见见朋友，也许喝上一两杯，不管怎样，离开公寓。于是他在下午中期动身，步行到非常附近的第14街车站。他上了开往市中心的2号线列车，在这节车厢里，有这四名青少年。他们当时玩得非常高兴。
They are joking around. They're laughing. Back in the day, Subways had these straps that hung down and they were swinging on. on those straps and goofing around and talking to people, hey, what's up? You got a light. And so Bernie Gett sits down and decides to sit right across from them, which, you know, is noteworthy to the teens because, of course, you know, nobody wants to sit next to teenagers. The train wasn't full, so Bernie Gatz didn't have to sit next to the teenagers, but he did.
他们正在开玩笑。他们在大笑。过去，地铁里有这种垂下来的吊带，他们就抓着那些吊带荡来荡去，瞎胡闹，跟人搭话，嘿，最近怎么样？你有火吗？于是伯尼·格茨坐了下来，决定坐在他们正对面，你知道的，这让青少年们觉得很显眼，因为当然啦，你知道的，没有人想坐在青少年旁边。当时车厢并不拥挤，所以伯尼·格茨没必要坐在青少年旁边，但他还是坐了。
And one of them who is really closest to him named Troy Canty is sort of interesting. interested in this. And he says, hey, you know, he greets him. And Bernie gets kind of gruffly, you know, so, you know, hey, responds back. And he's kind of encouraged. And he's encouraged in particular to ask this guy, does he have $5? So that was not a particularly weird thing for Troy Candy to say, hey, have you got five bucks? This is the 80s. And panhandling is the name of the game. You can't go anywhere in New York City in 1984 without somebody saying, hey, you got a dollar, you got five bucks. But Bernie doesn't like that. Bernie gets stands up.
其中一个离他最近、名叫特洛伊·坎蒂的人对此有点感兴趣。他开口说，嘿，你知道的，他打了个招呼。而伯尼·格茨有点粗鲁地，你知道的，所以，你知道的，嘿，回应了一声。这反而有点鼓励了他。特别是鼓励他去问这个人，有没有5美元？所以特洛伊·坎蒂说“嘿，你有五块钱吗”并不是什么特别奇怪的事。这是80年代。乞讨是家常便饭。你在1984年的纽约市走哪儿都能听到有人说，嘿，你有一块钱吗，你有五块钱吗。但伯尼不喜欢这样。伯尼·格茨站了起来。
He slowly turns. And in that moment, Trichante sort of thinks, wow, this guy's actually going to give me five bucks. Cool. But what happens is Bernie gets, stands up, reaches into the waistband of his slacks. And what he has there is a hidden holster. What Troy didn't know was that Bernie Gets routinely carried guns. And in New York, that was illegal to just carry a gun because you wanted to. So he'd actually purchased his guns illegally because he'd gone down to Florida and purchased them and brought them back.
他慢慢转过身。就在那一刻，特洛伊·坎蒂有点心想，哇，这家伙居然真的要给我五块钱。太酷了。但实际发生的是，伯尼·格茨站起身来，把手伸进裤腰里。他在那里藏了一个枪套。特洛伊不知道的是，伯尼·格茨经常随身带枪。在纽约，仅仅因为你想带枪就带枪是违法的。所以他其实是通过非法途径买的枪，因为他曾去过佛罗里达州买下它们并带了回来。
So Bernie has one of those illegal guns on him, a 38 Smith & Wesson. And now he pulls it out on the train. He swings around, assumes a combat position, and shoots Troy Canty, front on, straight in the chest, and immediately right behind Troy is his friend Barry Allen, who's not said a word to Bernadgett's. He horrified, tries to get away, tries to run, and Bernice shoots him in the back. And then there are friend James Ramzor, who's even further down the train, who's also said nothing to Bernie gets. He shoots him as he's trying to get away. in the arm, it goes through his side and ultimately into his lungs.
所以伯尼身上带着一把这样的非法枪支，一把.38史密斯韦森左轮手枪。现在他在车厢里把它掏了出来。他转过身，摆出战斗姿势，朝着特洛伊·坎蒂正面开枪，直接击中胸膛，而紧挨着特洛伊身后的是他的朋友巴里·艾伦，他甚至没对伯尼·格茨说过一句话。他惊恐万分，试图逃跑、试图逃走，而伯尼击中了她的背部。然后是他们的朋友詹姆斯·拉姆索尔，他在车厢更远的地方，同样没有对伯尼·格茨说过任何话。当他试图逃跑时，伯尼击中了其手臂，子弹穿过他的侧腹，最终射入他的肺部。
Now three of the four teens are on the floor of the train, bleeding. Troy Canty from a bullet to the chest. Barry Allen from a bullet to the back. James Ramsoor from a bullet to his arm and side. Bernie also fires at the 14, Darryl Kaby and misses. Shaking, Kaby sits down in the rear of the car, head down, and grips the edge of a seat, hoping that Bernie will just move on. And when Bernie Getz walks over to this fourth teenager, Darrell KB, he looks down at him and he says,
现在四名青少年中有三人倒在列车地板上流血。特洛伊·坎蒂胸部中弹。巴里·艾伦背部中弹。詹姆斯·拉姆索尔手臂和侧腹中弹。伯尼还向第4个人达雷尔·卡比开枪但打偏了。卡比浑身发抖，坐在车厢后部，低着头，紧紧抓着座椅边缘，希望伯尼能就此走开。当伯尼·格茨走向这第四名青少年达雷尔·卡比时，他低头看着对方并说道：
you look okay, here's another. And that's when he puts a gun straight in his side, pulls the trigger, thus severing his spinal cord and rendering him paralyzed for the rest of his life. While this is all happening, the conductor pulls the emergency brake and the train comes to a halt. So the train has stopped on the tracks in the darkness somewhere between 14th Street and Chamber Street in Lower Manhattan. Now, at that moment, gets appeared calm to passengers and it appeared almost poised, but he ultimately, knowing that the train would be swarmed with police in a matter of moments, just fled. Jumped off the train, ran through the subway platform with his gun, took a cab home, running a car, and fled to New Hampshire. The boys are hoisted out of the train and rushed to the hospital. All four were badly wounded, but Darrell Kaby is the worst off in a coma with a bullet in his spinal cord.
你看起来挺好，再吃一颗。就在这时，他把枪直接顶在卡比的肋部，扣动了扳机，从而切断了他的脊髓，导致他余生瘫痪。这一切发生的同时，列车长拉下了紧急制动闸，列车停了下来。于是列车在下曼哈顿第14街和钱伯斯街之间某个地方的黑暗轨道中停了下来。此刻，格茨在乘客们看来显得很冷静，甚至几乎是不慌不忙，但他最终还是逃跑了，因为他知道列车很快就会被警察包围。他跳下车，拿着枪跑过地铁站台，叫了一辆出租车回家，租了一辆车，逃往新罕布什尔州。男孩们被抬出列车并被紧急送往医院。四人都身受重伤，但达雷尔·卡比的情况最糟，陷入昏迷，脊髓里还留着一颗子弹。
He and Barry Allen are hurried into the operating room. And meanwhile, back on the train, the police are trying to make sense of what in the world just happened. And so what are they left with? They're left with the clothing of the boys who have been stripped so that they can be attended to medically. And the police discover that in the pockets of two of these young men, in particular it was Daryl K.B. and James Ramzor that they have screwdrivers. And initially, when they pull these screwdrivers out and they note them, they cataloged them, there had been no reason to think they'd ever been taken out. They were secured in their jackets. And that was kind of the end of it.
他和巴里·艾伦被紧急送往手术室。与此同时，回到列车上，警察正试图弄清楚到底发生了什么。那么他们手里留下了什么？他们留下了男孩们的衣服，这些衣服为了接受医疗救治已经被脱掉了。警察发现在其中两名年轻人的口袋里，具体来说是达雷尔·卡比和詹姆斯·拉姆索尔身上有螺丝刀。起初，当他们掏出这些螺丝刀并做记录时，把它们登记在案，没有任何理由认为这些螺丝刀曾被拿出来过。它们被安全地放在夹克口袋里。事情也就到此为止了。
The police logged the screwdrivers, but they don't think of them as relevant yet. Meanwhile, the whole system begins to mobilize to figure out what the boys could have done to justify the shooting. They're casting about combing the records to figure out what in the world record must these teenagers have. Because surely they must be criminals. Surely they must be responsible for the fact that they themselves now have bullet holes in them. And they quickly realize that these teenagers have racked up. a series of misdemeanor citations over the previous years. They'd been caught jumping the turnstile to avoid paying the subway fare and trying to steal quarters from an arcade.
警察登记了这些螺丝刀，但当时并不认为它们与此案有关。与此同时，整个体制开始调动起来，以查明这些男孩到底做了什么来为枪击辩护。他们到处搜查档案记录，以弄清楚这些青少年到底有什么犯罪记录。因为他们肯定一定是罪犯。他们肯定必须为自己身上现在多了几个弹孔负全职责任。他们很快意识到，这些青少年在过去几年里积累了一系列轻罪传票。他们曾因为了逃避地铁票价而跳过旋转闸门、以及试图从游戏机厅偷取25美分硬币而被抓获。
All of the citations were minor. If it weren't for the Getz case, none of those charges would ever bring them to court. But within a very short period of time, two Bronx judges make the executive decision that they're going to suddenly issue a blizzard of warrants for these teenagers' arrest. Meanwhile, the police are looking for Bernie so they can question him too. The search goes on today for the so-called subway vigilante. But already, the public isn't even sure the police should be doing that. Police reported receiving more than 500 calls, praising the man who shot the teenagers.
所有的传票都是轻微违规。要不是因为格茨案，这些指控永远不会把他们带上法庭。但在极短时间内，布朗克斯的两位法官做出了一项行政决定，他们将突然对这些青少年的逮捕签发大量的搜捕令和逮捕令。与此同时，警方正在搜寻伯尼，以便也能对其实施讯问。搜捕所谓地铁私刑者的行动仍在继续。但此时，公众甚至不确定警方是否应该这样做。警方报告称收到了500多通电话，赞美开枪射击青少年的那个人。
Bernie gets is celebrated by ordinary people. They champion him. They decide that he's innocent even before they know his name. They are furious that the DA's office will even consider prosecuting him. Before Bernard Gets was identified, the New York Post started calling him the, quote, Death Wish Vigilante. That's the nickname they gave him. And they started running graphics about the Death Wish vigilante after Charles Bronson,
伯尼·格茨受到了普通人的颂扬。他们支持他。甚至在知道他的名字之前，他们就认定他是无辜的。他们愤怒于地方检察官办公室居然会考虑起诉他。在伯尼·格茨被确认身份之前，《纽约邮报》开始称他为“引文中的《猛龙怪客》私刑者”。那是他们给他的绰号，他们开始围绕查尔斯·布朗森（电影《猛龙怪客》的主人公）来制作关于《猛龙怪客》私刑者的图文报道。
the protagonist of the movie Death Wish. So long before Bernie Gets had pulled that trigger, they were already really being primed with this rhetoric to identify with Bernie Gets. Bernie Gets, he's just minding his own business. He's a hardworking guy. He's a small business owner. Bernie was a regular guy. You know what I mean? He's a regular guy.
因此，早在伯尼·格茨扣动扳机之前，他们就已经在潜移默化中被这种言论灌输，从而对伯尼·格茨产生认同感。伯尼·格茨，他只是在管好自己的事。他是一个勤劳的人。他是个小企业主。伯尼是个普通人。你知道我的意思吗？他是个普通人。
There's no big thing about him, you know? And he gets on that train and four black thugs are going to try to harm him. And so that's all they need to know, right? Get spit the people of the city of New York a great favor. If it was me, I would have killed the guy. I mean, if it was me and I had to defend myself, I would have done exactly the same thing. I think he did right. They tried to mug him.
他身上没什么大不了的，你知道吗？然后他上了那列火车，四个黑人暴徒打算伤害他。所以这就是他们需要知道全部，对吧？格茨帮了纽约市人民一个大忙。如果是我，我早就把那家伙杀了。我的意思是，如果是我，如果我必须自卫，我会做完全一样的事。我认为他做得很对。他们试图抢劫他。
You, my kids, they wanted to. But there's one detail in this story, one piece of misinformation that really started to stand out, and it had to do with those screwdrivers. Police say the teenagers had arrest records, and three were carrying long screwdrivers. Police say the boys were armed with sharpened screwdrivers. Police say the boys were armed with sharpened screwdrivers. Now the media was reporting that even though the boys didn't have guns, they had weapons in the form of screwdrivers. And not just screwdrivers, sharpened ones.
你，我的孩子们，他们本想这么干的。但这个故事中有一个细节，一条错误的信息开始格外引人注目，它与那些螺丝刀有关。警方称这些青少年有犯罪前科，其中三人携带长螺丝刀。警方称这些男孩携带了削尖的螺丝刀。警方称这些男孩携带了削尖的螺丝刀。现在媒体报道说，尽管这些男孩没有枪，但他们以螺丝刀的形式携带了武器。而且不仅仅是螺丝刀，还是削尖的螺丝刀。
These were not sharpened screwdrivers. These were regular screwdrivers that they needed to jimmy open the coin receptacles at the local arcade. And it's not just the use of the sharpened screwdrivers, but the use of the term armed, the narrative that the four young men were armed with screwdrivers. Is itself a fiction? There was never any screwdriver shown to brandished or made available to Bernard Gets at any time. It is simply not true.
这些可不是什么削尖的螺丝刀。这些是他们用来撬开当地游戏机厅投币口的普通螺丝刀。而且不仅仅是使用了“削尖的螺丝刀”这个说法，还有“武装”这个词的使用，即这四名年轻人带着螺丝刀武装起来的这种说法。这本身就是虚构的。根本没有任何螺丝刀在任何时间被展示、挥舞或提供给伯尼·格茨。这完全不是真的。
But that didn't matter. After the New York Daily News reported it, its tabloid competitor, the New York Post, doubled down. Every major paper ran with this notion that the screwdrivers were sharpened. Police say they did find several sharpened screwdrivers in the coat pockets of the victim. According to police, carried sharpened heavy-duty screwdrivers.
但这并不重要。在《纽约每日新闻》报道之后，其竞争对手小报《纽约邮报》变本加厉。各大主流报纸都采用了螺丝刀被削尖了这种说法。警方称他们确实在受害者的外套口袋里发现了几个削尖的螺丝刀。据警方称，他们携带了削尖的重型螺丝刀。
And each time another news story mentioned it, it became more and more real. Four black teenagers wielding sharpened screwdrivers pressed him for $5. Eventually, even major mainstream publications like the New York Times and Time magazine, ran with this detail. All you knew it was a white guy that had shot four black teenagers
每当另一篇新闻报道提及此事时，它就变得越来越真实。四个手持削尖螺丝刀的黑人青少年向他勒索5美元。最终，就连《纽约时报》和《时代》杂志等主流主流出版物也采用了这个细节。你所知道的全部就是，一个白人枪击了四个黑人青少年，
who were armed with sharpened screwdrivers. And that stuck, and it taps into a long-running narrative in the United States over lifting up vigilantes and vigilante behavior. Still, even as these new stories are circulating, there's a big piece of the puzzle missing. Bernie, who had been on the lamb for nine days, still needed to be questioned. And he was about to finally emerge and give his own version of events. After nine days of traipsing around the snowy backroads of Vermont and New Hampshire, Bernie Getz finally decides to turn himself in.
而他们携带着削尖的螺丝刀。而这深入人心，它呼应了美国长期以来宣扬私刑正义和私刑行为的叙事。尽管这些新闻报道仍在流传，但拼图还缺少重要的一块。潜逃了九天的伯尼仍需要接受讯问。而他即将最终现身并给出他自己对事件版本的陈述。在佛罗里达州和新罕布什尔州雪地乡间小路上东奔西跑了九天之后，伯尼·格茨终于决定自首。
He walks into the police station in Concord, New Hampshire, and starts talking. I mean, again, this is all on videotape. Sure. Nothing that said in this room did off the videotape is for your protection and for hours. When he turns himself in, he voluntarily waives his right to a lawyer, and he proceeds to give a two-hour video. videotaped confession. And in that, he pulls no punches.
他走进了新罕布什尔州康科德的警察局，开始开口说话。我的意思是，再次强调，这一切都是录像录下来的。当然。在这个房间里说的任何没有录进录像带的话，都是为了保护你以及为了历时数小时。当他自首时，他自愿放弃了请律师的权利，并进行了一场长达两小时的录像审讯。录像供认。在供词中，他毫不避讳。
I wanted to kill those guys. I wanted to name those guys. I wanted to make them sucker in every way I could. If I had more bullets, I would have shot them all again and again. My problem was I ran out of bullets. And I was going to gouge one of the guys' eyes out with my keys afterwards. He makes clear that robbery had nothing to do with it. Look, they didn't have weapons.
我想杀了那些家伙。我想把那些家伙置于死地。我想用我能想到的各种方式痛击他们。如果我有更多子弹，我会一遍又一遍地把他们全射中。我的问题是我子弹用光了。事后我还要用钥匙挖出其中一个家伙的眼睛。他明确表示这与抢劫毫无关系。听着，他们根本没有武器。
And he says this a few times, even when, the DA, you know, clearly mystified as to why he would have done. I was almost like people are throwing him a lifeline. Well, you know, is it because you were mugged, you know, a few years earlier? He says, no, it had nothing to do with that, you know. Were you being robbed? And he says, no. He even admits to going up to Daryl Kaby, who was cowering in his seat and saying a line that shocks me every time I hear it.
而且他好几次都这么说，甚至当地方检察官显然对为什么他会这么做感到困惑时。这几乎就像人们在向他抛出救生圈。好吧，你知道的，是因为你几年前遭遇过抢劫吗？他说，不，这和那个无关，你知道的。你在被抢劫吗？他说，没有。他甚至承认走到蜷缩在座位上的达雷尔·卡比面前，说出了一句每当我听到都感到震惊的话。
When I saw this one fellow, when I saw the gleam in his eye and the smile on his face. I went to him the second time, and I looked at him, and I said, you seem to be doing all right. Here's another. Bernie was fed up with the city, with the boys, and he decided to take matters into his own hands. He had admitted to all of it. The question now was, would that matter? More than two years after the shooting, the case finally went to court. Bernie faced a 13-count indictment, and on paper, it looked like a slam dunk for prosecutors. On the one hand, you have a prosecutor who has everything on his side. He's got Bernie Gets' confession.
当我看到这个家伙时，当我看到他眼中的精光和脸上的微笑时。我第二次走向他，看着他，然后我说，你看起来挺好的。再吃一颗。伯尼对这座城市、对这些男孩感到厌倦，他决定自己采取行动。他对此供认不讳。现在的问题是，这重要吗？枪击案发生两年多后，此案终于开庭审理。伯尼面临13项罪名的起诉，从纸面上看，这对检察官来说似乎是一场十拿九稳的官司。一方面，检察官占尽天时地利人和。他有伯尼·格茨的供词。
He's got very badly injured victims. You know, the facts are on his side. But Bernie Gets is already winning in the court of public opinion. And he has hired a very, very important lawyer by the name of Barry Slotnick, who was going to, in effect, bamboozle the jury. Barry Slotnick couldn't have been more out of central casting. When you think of the kind of glitzy showbiz type attorney, Barry Slotnick was it. He had tailored Italian suits. He had jewelry, the tie tack.
他有伤势极其严重的受害者。你知道，事实站在他这一边。但伯尼·格茨在舆论法庭上已经赢了。他请了一位非常非常重要的律师，名叫巴里·斯洛特尼克（Barry Slotnick），他实际上将要把陪审团忽悠过去。巴里·斯洛特尼克简直就是好莱坞大片里走出来的标准人物。当你想到那种浮华的名人秀场型律师时，巴里·斯洛特尼克就是那样的人。他穿着量身定制的意大利西装。他戴着珠宝，系着领带夹。
He had an alligator skin briefcase in each hand. He's chauffered in a Cadillac. He smoked cigarettes. He had represented many high. profile members, I believe, with the Colombo crime family. So he was a mob lawyer. So on one side, you have this shiny mob lawyer representing Bernie Gatz. And on the other, there's the prosecutor tasked with proving the boys were the victims. And the jury is waiting to hear from both sides. You know, when you describe the contours of the case to anyone, they have a hard time coming up
他手里各提着一个鳄鱼皮公文包。他坐着凯迪拉克专车。他抽着香烟。我记得他曾代理过科伦坡犯罪家族的许多高调成员。所以他是个黑帮律师。所以一方面，你有一个光鲜亮丽的黑帮律师代表伯尼·格茨。另一方面，则是负责证明这些男孩是受害者的检察官。陪审团正等待着听取双方的陈述。你知道，当你向任何人描述案件的大致轮廓时，他们很难猜出
with what the defense is going to be. But could you boil it down for me? What was the sort of nature of the defense's case? The defense's case was multifold. I think the big part of it is, and Barry Slotnick says this in his opening statement, I am going to put these young men on trial. And frankly, I don't think he called them young men. It was thugs and hoodlums and savages and whatever else. And he framed it as a gang, a street gang that sought to terrorize,
辩方会采取什么辩护策略。但你能为我概括一下吗？辩方案件的性质究竟是什么？辩方的辩护是多方面的。我认为其中的很大一部分是，巴里·斯洛特尼克在他的开场陈词中就这么说了，我将要把这些年轻人送上审判台。坦率地说，我不认为他称他们为年轻人。那是暴徒、流氓、野蛮人和诸如此类的人。他将其定性为一个帮派，一个企图恐怖统治的街头帮派，
if not Bernard gets, whoever was the next unlucky victim of their vicious path. The judge banned explicit talk of race at the trial, but race was always front of mind. They never said black, they never said it, but they used language of savages, thugs, animals, monsters, hoodlums. The defense was not shy about doing everything they possibly could to stoke the racial biases of the jury. And it wasn't just the language he used. One of the first things Slotnick and his team did was deliberately seek out photographs, where the young men looked their most menacing. Giant 24 by 36 or whatever black and white posters
即使不是针对伯尼·格茨，也是针对他们那邪恶路途上下一个不幸的受害者。法官在审判中禁止明确谈论种族，但种族始终是人们脑海中最优先考虑的事。他们从不说黑人，他们从不直说，但他们使用了野蛮人、暴徒、动物、怪物、流氓之类的语言。辩方毫不避讳地竭尽所能去煽动陪审团的种族偏见。这不仅仅体现在他使用的语言上。斯洛特尼克和他的团队做的第一件事之一，就是刻意寻找这些年轻人看起来最具威胁性的照片。巨大的24乘36英寸或其他尺寸的黑白海报，
of these four young men in which the young men just didn't look friendly. Slotnick even put those pictures on easels in front of the jury. For no reason. Remember, these are victims. These were not perpetrators or criminals. This isn't evidence. But every day when they walked in, these menacing looking photographs of these four young black men would be staring at the jury because they wanted the jury to see who these men were
上面是这四名年轻人，照片里的年轻人看起来一点也不友好。斯洛特尼克甚至把这些照片放在陪审团面前的画架上。毫无理由。记住，这些人是受害者。他们不是行凶者或罪犯。这不是证据。但每天他们走进来时，这四名年轻黑人男子充满威胁感的照片都会盯着陪审团，因为他们希望陪审团看到这些男人是谁，
and draw their own conclusions from that. Then about a month into the trial, Slotnick pulled out the big guns. One morning they went in to court and taped out a model of the train car on the floor of the courtroom. Slotnick was staging what was supposed to be a reenactment of the shooting. But very quickly, it was clear that almost nothing about it resembled what actually happened. They brought in four of the meanest, looking black guys, they could find it, and dress them up in dirty jeans and white t-shirts
并从中得出他们自己的结论。接着，在审判大约进行了一个月后，斯洛特尼克亮出了杀手锏。一天早上，他们走进法庭，在法庭地板上用胶带标出了车厢模型。斯洛特尼克正在上演一场本应是枪击案重演的戏码。但很快，人们就清楚地看到，这几乎没有一点像真实发生过的事情。他们找来了他们能找到的最凶神恶煞的四个黑人小伙，给他们穿上脏牛仔裤和白T恤，
and had them represent the four young men. So the representation of the boys was already inaccurate, but they also didn't try to replicate any of the other conditions on the train that day. The recreation didn't show any of the other passengers who had been there, and instead of trying to recreate where the boys were actually sitting or standing, the four actors were directed to stand in a semicircle. around the stand-in for Bernie Gets. Think of all of the various factors that would have been at play,
让他们代表这四名年轻人。因此，对这些男孩的代表本身就不准确，而且他们也没有试图复制那天火车上的任何其他环境条件。这次重现没有展示当时在那里的任何其他乘客，而且这四名演员没有被指示去重现男孩们当时实际坐着或站着的位置，而是被指示站在一个半圆里，围绕着扮演伯尼·格茨的替身。想想所有本应发挥作用的各种因素，
but all it was was a taped-out model of the car with four mean-looking black teenagers grabbing and tugging and shoving and pulling the model Bernard Gets. The judge eventually stopped the demonstration. But the damage was done. The jury saw what the defense wanted them to see, which was four young black men beating up a white man. And that's it.
但这一切不过是一个用胶带标出的车厢模型，里面有四个看起来很凶恶的黑人青少年抓着、拽着、推着、拉着模型伯尼·格茨。法官最终叫停了这次演示。但损害已经造成。陪审团看到了辩方希望他们看到的东西，那就是四个年轻的黑人男子在殴打一个白人男子。就是这样。
In essence, this is how most people, the trial goes. The defense continued to use racialized language and stereotypes to amp up the jurors' larger fears and anxieties about the city. And to use all of this to prove that Bernie was acting in self-defense, that he was reasonable to think that he was about to be robbed or mugged. They even explained away his confession. The defense made the decision, a very risky one, but said that this was a frightened man. And even though he's openly confessing, he was unambiguous. And I intended to murder these men and to make them suffer as possible. Those were his words. But because he was scared and out of his mind, that meant that we should discredit the words that come out of his mouth.
从本质上讲，这就是大多数人眼中审判的走向。辩方继续使用带种族色彩的语言和刻板印象，来放大陪审团对这座城市的巨大恐惧和焦虑。并利用这一切来证明伯尼是在正义防卫，证明他认为自己即将遭到抢劫或打劫是合理的。他们甚至为他的供词进行了辩解。辩方做出了一个决定，一个非常冒险的决定，但声称这是一个受惊吓的人。尽管他公开供认不讳，而且表态毫不含糊。我本意就是要谋杀这些人，并让他们备受折磨。那是他的原话。但因为他当时吓坏了、失去了理智，这就意味着我们应当对从他嘴里说出来的话不予采信。
It was very risky. But ultimately, the strategy paid off. In June 1987, the jury acquitted Bernie Getz of the most serious charges against him, not guilty of attempted murder, not guilty of assaulting the four boys. The only thing he was held accountable for was the possession of illegal firearms. And in the end, he only served eight months. What is the sort of basic legal reason for the jury? Just explain to me why the jury, you know, voted not to convict him. The legal reason goes back to this question of reasonableness.
这非常冒险。但最终，这一策略奏效了。1987年6月，陪审团裁定伯尼·格茨针对他的最严重罪名不成立，蓄意谋杀罪名不成立，袭击四名男孩罪名不成立。他唯一被追究责任的是非法持有枪支罪。最后，他只服刑了八个月。陪审团做出无罪判决的某种基本法律原因是什么？请向我解释一下为什么陪审团，你知道的，投票不给他定罪。法律原因要追溯到“合理性”这个古老的问题。
The law in the state of New York says, one can use deadly or lethal force if he reasonably believes he's about to be a victim of a robbery. And after doing that analysis, the jury felt that gets was reasonably afraid. And they think that what they were simply doing was applying the law, saying, in a rough environment, in a rough city, this individual was reasonable in his belief that a a mugging might have been imminent. The Getz case actually set a new legal precedent around that question. When is it reasonable for someone to act in self-defense? Before the case, the New York State Legislature hadn't clearly defined what reasonable meant.
纽约州的法律规定，如果一个人合理地认为自己即将成为抢劫的受害者，他就可以使用致命或杀伤性武力。在进行了那番分析之后，陪审团认为格茨的恐惧是合理的。他们认为他们自己所做的一直都是在适用法律，也就是说，在严酷的环境中，在一座严酷的城市里，这个人相信抢劫可能迫在眉睫的信念是合理的。格茨案实际上围绕这个问题确立了一项新的法律先例。一个人在何时进行自卫才是合理的？在此案之前，纽约州立法机构并没有对“合理”的含义做出清晰的定义。
And the question was, is reasonableness subjective in the sense that if you genuinely feel scared in your heart, that's enough. I feel scared, therefore I can use deadly force. or objective, I'm going to use deadly force and that tracks with how we would assume other people in society would behave. That compares my behavior to everyone else's. And those are two different ways that courts around the country had grappled with how to use the term. This question is so contentious. It actually goes up to the highest court in New York, which decides once and for all to clarify it. Technically, they say, you have to consider both things, what the person is.
而问题在于，合理性是主观的吗？即如果你内心确实感到害怕，这就够了。我感到害怕，因此我可以使用致命武力。还是客观的，即我将使用致命武力，这符合我们假设社会中其他人会表现出的行为方式。这会将我的行为与所有其他人的行为进行比较。这是全国各地法院一直在努力如何使用该术语的两种不同方式。这个问题如此具有争议。它甚至一直闹到了纽约最高法院，该法院最终决定一劳永逸地澄清它。从技术上讲，他们表示，你必须同时考虑两件事，这个人在
was afraid of and what an average reasonable person would be afraid of. But as we see in the Bernie Gett's case, even considering that definition of reasonable, what the average person might do still ultimately comes down to a very subjective opinion. This measure of reasonableness seems to have just, I don't know, we seem to accept a lot of more of this. Yeah. We have no evidence to suggest that a robbery was imminent, but the mere fact that, that one might have sincerely thought that a mugging was coming would have allowed him to kill them under the law. Like if he'd succeeded and actually commited the act, consummated the act of
害怕什么，以及一个普通合理的人会害怕什么。但正如我们在伯尼·格茨案中所看到的，即使考虑到“合理”的定义，普通人可能会做什么最终仍然归结为一个非常主观的观点。这种合理性的标准似乎已经，我不知道，我们似乎接受了更多这种事情。是的。我们没有任何证据表明抢劫迫在眉睫，但仅仅因为某人可能真诚地认为抢劫即将发生，根据法律，这就允许他杀死他们。就像如果他成功了并且真正实施了行为、完成了
homicide, that would have been protected under New York law. And which is just sort of, it's one of the realities of the American conception of self-defense that we don't ever really stop to think about, which might lead to innocent people getting shot preemptively. And we as a society sort of make peace with that. So if that's the legal reason why Gets got off, do you have a take on what the real reason was? Like, what do people say? It's both my knowledge of the system and cynicism as a former prosecutor. And I would say, honestly, the jury saw themselves in Bernard Gettz.
凶杀行为，那将受到纽约法律的保护。而这仅仅是，这是美国自卫概念中我们从不真正停下来思考的现实之一，这可能会导致无辜的人被先发制人地枪杀。而我们作为一个社会却对此习以为常。所以，如果那是格茨脱罪的法律原因，你对真正的原因有什么看法？比如，人们是怎么说的？这既源于我对法律体系的了解，也源于我作为前检察官的玩世不恭。老实说，我认为陪审团在伯尼·格茨身上看到了他们自己。
Another jury could easily have convicted him of attempted murder, starting with the fact that he says, on the record, to police, knowingly, involuntarily, I intended to murder them. In an attempted murder trial, that's a confession. And so this idea that he was scared and out of his mind means that we should discredit the words that come out of his mouth is to me that's just ludicrous. That's nonsense. But they saw themselves in him. Ten of the 12 jury members were white. Half of the jury had actually been victims of crime, some of them, on the subway.
另一个陪审团本可以轻易以谋杀未遂罪将他定罪，从他知情且自愿对警方所说的话开始：“我有意谋杀他们。”在谋杀未遂审判中，这就是一份供词。因此，这种认为他当时吓坏了、失去了理智，因而我们应不予采信他口中说出的话的说法，在我看来简直荒谬绝伦。那是无稽之谈。但他们在他的身上看到了他们自己。12名陪审团成员中有10名是白人。陪审团中有一半人实际上曾是犯罪受害者，其中一些人就是在地铁上。
They were primed to see themselves in Gets. and to see the boys as attackers. And if you believe the papers, attackers wielding sharpened screwdrivers. Every single serious source who have looked at this has debunked the sharpened screwdriver's theory. And again, that to me extends not just to whether they were sharpened, but the use of the term armed when referring to the teenagers. Because number one, we know the purpose for which they had the screwdrivers.
他们从一开始就被灌输了在格茨身上看到自己的心态。并将这些男孩视为袭击者。如果你相信报纸的话，那就是手持削尖螺丝刀的袭击者。每一个研究过此事的严肃消息来源都揭穿了“削尖螺丝刀”的理论。再次强调，在我看来，这不仅延伸到它们是否被削尖，还延伸到了在提及这些青少年时使用“武装”这个词。因为第一，我们知道他们携带螺丝刀的目的。
And number two, we know that they at no point attempted to even threaten to use them with respect to Bernard Getz. And yet, at the end of the day, in a narrative very familiar to today that we all inhabit, the facts won't matter because people will want to somehow exonerate him anyway. In the same way that the Getz case acted as a kind of stress test for the legal definitions behind self-defense, it was, also a testing ground for something else. In the late 70s, Rupert Murdoch, then an ambitious conservative media mogul, came to the states with the dream of dominating the U.S. market, starting with buying The New York Post. And he quickly understands that one of the most important things that you need when you're going to dominate a media market is you need readers. And one of the easiest ways to get readers is to kind of keep hitting them with salacious stories that just baffle them. And
第二，我们知道他们在任何时候都没有试图对伯尼·格茨做出甚至威胁要使用它们的举动。然而归根结底，在一个与我们今天所处的、我们所有人都在其中的十分熟悉的叙事中，事实根本不重要，因为人们无论如何都会想要为他开脱。就像格茨案充当了自卫背后法律定义的某种压力测试一样，它也是其他事物的试验田。70年代末，鲁珀特·默多克（Rupert Murdoch），当时一位雄心勃勃的保守派媒体大亨，带着称霸美国市场的梦想来到美国，从收购《纽约邮报》开始。他很快明白，当你准备主导一个媒体市场时，你需要的最重要的东西之一就是读者。而获取读者最简单的方法之一，就是不断用那些让他们感到困惑的、耸人听闻的故事去轰炸他们。还有
them and defy imagination. I'll give you just one example of that that just exemplifies this moment so well. A reporter from the New York Post was later interviewed about the reporting in the post in these years. And this reporter gave an example of how there'd be an event. And a post reporter would be on the scene and sort of ask the police officer, like a crime and say, do you know what happened? You know, who are your suspects? What's going on? And the police officers, They know we're still investigating it. And the reporter would say, well, you know, have you ruled out this? Have you ruled out that?
那些颠覆想象的故事。我只给你举一个这方面的例子，它完美地诠释了那个时刻。《纽约邮报》的一名记者后来接受了关于该报近年来报道的采访。这名记者举了一个例子，说明当时会发生某起事件。而《纽约邮报》的记者会出现在现场，有点像问警察，比如一起犯罪，然后说，你知道发生了什么吗？你知道，你们的嫌疑人是谁？到底怎么回事？而警察则回答，你知道的，我们还在调查中。记者就会说，嗯，你知道的，你排除了这个吗？你排除了那个吗？
And like, you know, have you ruled out a homosexual angle? And of course, the police officer's like, look, we haven't ruled out anything. You know, we're still investigating. And then the headline would be homosexual angle not ruled out in this crime, right? So, you know, the Bernie Gett's case was really ground zero for this in New York City. And really the nation, because Rupert Murdoch's New York Post, will become Fox News, and Bernie Gets will become that every man, that resentful, rage-filled, every man, that over time will be allowed to do whatever he wants, even legally, as long as he just says he felt threatened.
然后，你知道的，你们有没有排除同性恋的可能？当然，警方的态度是，听着，我们什么都没有排除。你知道的，我们还在调查。然后头条新闻就会变成，这起犯罪不排除同性恋的可能，对吧？所以，你知道的，伯尼·格茨案真的是纽约市这种现象的起点。实际上也是全美国的起点，因为鲁珀特·默多克的《纽约邮报》将成为福克斯新闻，而伯尼·格茨将成为那个平民代表、那个充满怨恨和愤怒的平民代表，随着时间的推移，他将被允许做他想做的任何事，甚至是合法的，只要他说他感到受到了威胁。
In the decades after, we have had more people enacting the Death Wish fantasy, taking their idea of justice into their own hands. In 2012, George Zimmerman, a neighborhood watch volunteer in Sanford, Florida, saw a black teenager in a dark hoodie walking down the street. Zimmerman said he thought the teen was casing the area, looking for houses to rob. But rather than wait for police, Zimmerman got out of his car and gunned down 17-year-old Trayvon Martin. Trayvon had no weapons, only a bag of skittles in his pocket. In 2020, Kyle Rittenhouse showed up at a Black Live. Matter protest in Kenosha, Wisconsin with an AR-15-style rifle. He said he went to protect local businesses to do what he thought law enforcement could not.
在随后的几十年里，我们有更多的人在演绎《虎胆妙算》式的幻想，将他们对正义的理解付诸实际。2012年，佛罗里达州桑福德的社区治安志愿者乔治·齐默尔曼看到一个穿着黑色连帽衫的黑人少年走在街上。齐默尔曼说他认为这个少年在踩点，寻找要抢劫的房子。但齐默尔曼没有等警察来，而是下车开枪打死了17岁的特雷沃恩·马丁。特雷沃恩没有武器，口袋里只有一包彩虹糖。2020年，凯尔·里滕豪斯带着一把AR-15式步枪出现在威斯康星州基诺沙的“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动中。他说他是去保护当地企业，去做他认为执法部门做不到的事情。
Rittenhouse shot three people, killing two, and wounding another. The modern-day version of this kind of unleashing of rage and violence is perhaps not surprisingly much more extreme. How can it be that Kyle Rittenhouse can literally show up at a protest? guns in hand and shoot three people, kill people, and have people celebrate him. Powell Rittenhouse struck us as bright, decent, sincere, dutiful, and hardworking. Exactly the kind of person you'd want many more of in your country. Then in 2023, Daniel Penny, a former Marine, got on the same New York City subway as Jordan Neely, a 30-year-old unarmed black man.
里滕豪斯枪击了三人，造成两人死亡，一人受伤。这种释放愤怒和暴力的现代版本或许并不令人意外地更加极端。怎么可能凯尔·里滕豪斯能公然出现在抗议活动中？手持枪支并枪击三人、杀害他人，还能让人为他庆祝。保罗·里滕豪斯给我们留下的印象是聪明、正派、真诚、尽责、勤奋。这正是你希望你的国家拥有更多的那种人。接着在2023年，前海军陆战队员丹尼尔·彭尼登上了与30岁未婚黑人男子乔丹·尼利相同的纽约地铁。
Neely was in the middle of a mental health crisis. and he began to shout and act erratically. Penny grabbed Neely from behind, brought him to the ground, and placed him in a chokehold for several minutes. Daniel Penny, like Bernie Getz, deemed him threatening, and killed him. And here, just like the other two cases,
尼利正处于心理健康危机的漩涡中，他开始大喊大叫，举止异常。彭尼从后面抓住尼利，将他按倒在地，并对其实施了数分钟的颈部锁喉。丹尼尔·彭尼和伯尼·格茨一样，认为他具有威胁，并杀害了他。在这里，就像其他两个案件一样，
the same thing happened. They all claim self-defense, and they're all lionized. Daniel Penny was a good Samaritan, put his own life at risk. I think he deserves a medal. New York needs this. And this support, it doesn't stop with conservative media.
同样的事情发生了。他们都声称是正当防卫，并且都被奉为英雄。丹尼尔·彭尼是个好撒玛利亚人，冒着生命危险。我认为他配得上勋章。纽约需要这个。这种支持并没有止步于保守派媒体。
It reaches beyond two billionaire businessmen, even the president of the United States. Just put on your imagination hat and imagine if Daniel Penny is a black man and Jordan Neely is a white man. Daniel Penny kills Jordan Neely in a chokehold. Close your eyes and imagine. Does Donald Trump invite him to sit in his private box at the Army-Navy game weeks later after his acquittal? And I think the answer is no. Does Andresen Horowitz, the most prestigious venture capital firm on the planet, give him a job offer days after his acquittal? And I think, again, the answer is no. In the end, all three men are acquitted of all assault charges,
它延伸到了两位亿万富翁商人，甚至还有美国总统。发挥你的想象力，想象一下如果丹尼尔·彭尼是个黑人，而乔丹·尼利是个白人。丹尼尔·彭尼用锁喉杀死了乔丹·尼利。闭上眼睛想象一下。在无罪释放几周后，唐纳德·特朗普会邀请他坐在陆海军橄榄球赛的私人包厢里吗？我想答案是否定的。安德森·霍洛维茨，这个星球上最负盛名的风险投资公司，会在他无罪释放几天后给他提供工作机会吗？我想，答案同样是否定的。最后，这三名男子都被判所有指控无罪，
just as Bernie Getz had been. In fact, in the penny case, when the jury asked for clarification on the question of what was reasonable, the judge specifically referred them back to the precedent set in the Gets trial. And that's not the only way that Bernie keeps coming up in these vigilante cases. He is still very much lionized.
就像伯尼·格茨一样。事实上，在彭尼案中，当陪审团要求澄清什么是“合理”的问题时，法官明确让他们参考了格茨审判中确立的判例。这并不是伯尼在这些治安维持案件中被提及的唯一方式。他依然非常受到吹捧。
He was asked what he thought about Kyle Rittenhouse's verdict. He was asked what he thought about Daniel Penny's verdict. He's still able to be the hero of his story. While Bernie Gets is still invoked again and again, the four teenagers have sort of disappeared. Meanwhile, James Ramzor is dead. He killed himself on one of the anniversaries of this shooting.
有人问他对凯尔·里滕豪斯案的判决有何看法。有人问他对丹尼尔·彭尼案的判决有何看法。他依然能够成为自己故事里的英雄。当伯尼·格茨一次又一次地被提起时，那四名少年却几乎已经消失了。与此同时，詹姆斯·拉姆佐尔已经死了。他在这次枪击事件的某个周年纪念日自杀了。
Things weren't much better for his three friends. In 1996, KB's family did win a civil suit against Gets. They were awarded $43 million in damages, but they never received a penny. Gets soon declared bankruptcy, and KB receded from the news. Barry Allen died too, after years. of struggling with drug addiction. Troy Canty is the only one of the four who managed to eke out some kind of an independent life afterwards. And he doesn't want to talk to anybody very understandably because he doesn't trust that his story will actually be honored.
他的三个朋友的情况也没有好到哪里去。1996年，KB的家属确实赢得了针对格茨的民事诉讼。他们被判获得4300万美元的赔偿金，但他们从未收到一分钱。格茨很快宣布破产，KB也逐渐淡出了新闻视野。巴里·艾伦也死了，在经历了多年的毒瘾挣扎之后。特洛伊·坎蒂是四人中唯一一个设法在事后过上某种独立生活的人。而且他非常可以理解地不想跟任何人说话，因为他不相信自己的故事会真正受到尊重。
And what happened with the myth of the sharpened screwdriver? The myth of the sharpened screwdriver remains. Bernard Gets, as recently as Kyle Rittenhouse, was in an interview referring to the sharpened screwdrivers. The sharpened screwdrivers are evoked to explain why Bernie Gets had done what he did. It was just a narrative that took off from the first day, and now 42 years later, it still is not really back in the bag. A history of the United States and 100 objects is a production of 99% invisible and be. BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Ellie Lightfoot. Our other producers are Priscilla Alabi and Brenna Daldorf. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher.
那被削尖的螺丝刀的神话又如何呢？被削尖螺丝刀的神话依然存在。就在凯尔·里滕豪斯案期间，伯尼·格茨还在一次采访中提到了削尖的螺丝刀。提到削尖的螺丝刀是为了解释为什么伯尼·格茨会做出他所做的事情。这只是一种从第一天起就开始流传的叙事，而现在42年过去了，它依然没有真正平息。《美国简史与100件物品》是99% Invisible与BBC Studios联合制作的节目。由我罗马·马尔斯主持和策划。本集由埃利·莱特富特制作。我们的其他制作人是普里西拉·阿拉比和布雷娜·达尔多夫。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。
This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% of Visible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California.
本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。艾米·布雷肯负责事实核查。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制作人是凯西·2。来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是尚·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特，插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯制作。99% Visible是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部设在美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 objects at 99PI. dot org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而BBC Studios的总部位于美丽的伦敦西部白城。如果您想与我们联系，或有物品让我们考虑，请发邮件至100 objects at 99PI dot org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。